[Musik]
mittlerweile ist einer der größten und
schwierigsten fälle
mit einer meldung
international fordern
[Musik]
am 12 10 2011 wird italia barriere von
ihren sohn und ihren feind
von italien 29 jahre alt 1 meter 70 groß
sie war als leader und nach england
gezogen um sich und ihrem sohn ein
besseres leben zu ermöglichen
sie war seit wenigen monaten im land
größter wunsch war es ihrem sohn die
bestmögliche zu geben
vitalia steht für gewöhnlich vor ihrem
sohn auf da sie um 50 zur arbeit
normalerweise wird sie von einem
kollegen mit
doch die hat einen
doch als er dort ankam war italien nicht
zu sehen als ihr freund scheint bei der
firma anrufer leistet das kann ich bei
der arbeit gewesen sei
da ihre angehörigen suchen beginnt die
polizei
sie wurden vor allem 50 flieger
nachbarin in ihrer küche gesehen
bei dieser moment in der küche war das
letzte mal dass wir leben
[Musik]
99 13 der vermissten personen tauchen
eine ein laues bis 24 stunden wieder auf
gesund und munter aber wir waren hier
ein hinweis sein muss nach dem 15
jährigen jungen niemals im stich
gelassen
von festlicher gewalt geworden
[Musik]
vitalia und romantisch lernen sich in
litauen
sie ist damals erst sie bis sie bekommen
einen sohn und heiraten 2007 drei jahre
später lassen sie sich scheiden und
vitalia zieht nach
dass wegen chronischer gewählt
doch es erscheint nicht vor gericht
daraufhin wird ein haftbefehl
england verlassen
[Musik]
die ersten zwei drei tage in einer
ermittlung sind
dass man in dieser zeit nicht erklären
kann dass die
spieler entwickelt sich weiter
zu hause
über alles erscheint
meine frau hatte verständnis dass ich
wenn so etwas passiert
die polizei warnt die mantas nach von 24
stunden hat
er hätte sie nicht gesehen und sie würde
ich selbst ihr geld
damit für die einzige hessische vor der
polizei und in eine sackgasse denn wenn
jemand es ist über 2000 kilometer
entfernt in litauen
wurde am montag dem 15 august in den
fall eingeschaltet
meine kollegen da jemand anriefen werden
sie einen ausländischen
nicht im land und daher nicht darin
verwickelt sein könnte
aber wir haben genau nach
sie zeigten
[Musik]
als es vom britischen mobilfunk mez
registriert wurde china wird willkommen
in groß beteiligt sind die
mobilfunkdaten widerlegen genannter
seine aussage dass er seit sechs monaten
nicht den großen teil hingewiesen
sie zeigen dass sie am 11 august kurz
vor mitternacht in dover an karneval ist
[Musik]
das war ein herber rückschlag
er war für eine ganze reihe von fragen
auf
so war sein name nicht unter den
passagieren
vier tage nach der vermisstmeldung in
für die litauische polizei eine razzia
auf riemann das grundstück durch
dort befindet sich ein weißer mercedes
benz wenn mit dem nummernschild
[Musik]
august 2011 von einer fähre in dover
großbritannien eingefahren
wurde
von mobilfunk
wir sahen uns die überwachungsvideos an
mit dem kinder
[Musik]
überzeugt dass niemand das und riemer
seine
person war
[Musik]
massa macht einfach richtig
aufbrausend und gewalttätig er hatte er
gedroht sie in eine kiste zu sperren
er wollte
das ist es angst vor
[Musik]
wo er war
befand sich dort auf
als nächstes ermittlerteam im umkreis
von
wartungs kameras beschränkt sein
bei face kameras werden die aufnahmen
bereits 24 stunden
eine überwachungskamera der 90 meter von
witali als wohnhaus entfernt war zeigte
eine frau die gegen ihren willen von
einem mann die straße hinunter gezerrt
wurde er schleppte sie zu einem auto
der mann war schwer zu erkennen aber die
frau sei vital war sehr nämlich
die uhrzeit und die roboter entsprachen
ihrem arbeitsweg
25 am 12 august
[Musik]
das fahrzeug im land war wir prüfen sie
die überwachungskamera auf der strecke
von dauerhaft
von einer kamera mit automatischer
und seine bewegungen abwickeln
kameras auf dem weg
eine weitere überwachungskamera in dem
kriegsgebiet und es zeigt dass jemand es
veränderung 56 in einer leben stand
aus diesem haus ist sie an dem morgen
gekommen
unter gelaufen
[Applaus]
und packen
diese sind einige straßen unter
gestreut hat
[Musik]
hier wird klar
als erfahrener ermittler weiß ich dass
am orde in diesem land mit häuslicher
gewalt beginnen und dann den zuschlag
dennoch hatte ich oft nicht der fall war
[Musik]
wir möchten in einem entführungsfall
wir haben nach jedem strohhalm genommen
in der hoffnung sie lebend zu finden bis
man die leiche findet entführungsfall
beantragten einen internationalen test
wir wollten ihn kriegen
kurz vor unserem geplanten zugriff
erfüllen wir in unseren kollegen aus
litauen dass er versuchte den märz
wieder zu verkaufen
[Musik]
und haben mit ihm am telefon eine
testfahrt aus
[Musik]
dann sendet
und es wird fest gemacht um an
großbritannien ausgeliefert zu werden in
der zwischenzeit in forensischer
untersucht
oder blut
[Musik]
das fahrzeug wurde modifiziert
schreiben und ich sind sehr offen heraus
gegangen sind war auch dessen platz im
koffer aus
genau die teile an denen sich unsere
spuren hätten wurden
aber die werden vollkommen die sagen wir
konnten keine spur von details sind
allerdings
entdeckten sie ihre massen erwartet
alles deutete auf ihre frische
kapital hatte kein geld abgehoben keine
verwandten oder freunde kontaktiert
sie hätte wieder ihre bankkarte handy
benutzt hätte sie normalerweise getan
sie war spurlos verschwunden
nun muss sie nun davon ausgehen dass
jemand an großbritannien ausgeliefert
des mordes angeklagt würde und auf der
polizei machen von frau wollte ihm fehlt
aber gebracht
das problematische an dem europäischen
haftbefehl
dass der angeklagte nicht zu dem
anklagepunkt vernommen werden darin
ich wusste dass ich
musste mir zu sagen dass wir
[Musik]
das gesetz verboten wir ihnen genau die
frage zu stellen die man macht wenn
ich da aber das risiko eingehen
ich wollte ihren dazu musste ich ihn
fragen wo sie war
[Musik]
ich habe zwei sehr erfahrene nicht damit
beauftragt ihm die entscheidende frage
zu stellen
diese frage hat er sie angegriffen
ich habe das foto von lausanne tisch
legten und sagten
werden sie den jungen erklären was sie
getan haben
sie schienen zu verlagern dass
wir das
[Musik]
eine entscheidende rolle spielen
würden nun mussten wir uns auf die
technischen hinweise konnte
sein handy die automatische nummer
vergangen und die überwachungskameras
[Musik]
offensichtlich des winters nur jahre
hinaus
aber seine reaktion auf das navi ließ
vermuten dass dieses gerät und sagen
könnte was wirklich passiert ist
wie wird mehrere wochen lang sie von
kriminaltechnikern untersucht
sun schreibt der prozess sollte märz
2012 beginnen bis dahin mussten wir die
leiche finch und das hatte oberste
priorität
[Musik]
um relevante daten offenbar
übersehen
vielleicht 14 möglichkeiten die
entscheidenden daten zu extrahieren
also habe ich
das auf digitale technik spezialisiert
wir einen völlig anderen ergebnis
damit es uns ansehen es war bereits
seine untersucht worden sie konnten ihm
keine relevanten daten entnehmen aber
martin war überzeugt es ist nach wie
entscheiden der information helfern
konnte
[Musik]
dieses modells
bundesanleihen in unserer sozialisten
gegeben hin dass geräte in seine
einzelteile zerlegt hat
er sah dass sich im inneren eine
speicherkarte befand noch wichtiger das
seinen arbeiter gab
ein wesentlicher schlüssel taten und
werden die beiden speicher da ist
eigentlichen gerät unter
[Musik]
soldaten eine sache von einem mann
innerhalb weniger für martin brüning
alle daten liefern
jede straße
die mantas gefahren ist jede route die
er genossen hat man jede stelle die er
an erhalten hat
das gerät jede seiner fahrt auf
[Musik]
wir waren uns sicher dass uns das navi
zu italiens leiche führen würde strom
label wir vermuteten dass ein mann das
sie in der näheren umgebung
aber
[Musik]
diese gegend ist nicht ohne mit sg
sümpfe und viel wald studie das machte
die sowie sehr aufwändig zeitintensiv
[Musik]
sagen das flusswasser aus den gesamten
see
investieren so viel energie auf diesen
mann das gelände präzise durch
ist die enttäuschung
[Musik]
nicht
das ganze
[Musik]
deshalb mussten wir sicherstellen dass
sie sich hier betragen
alle interessierten mehrfach gründlich
inspiziert
[Musik]
wir haben teams kunde fuß patrons und
wärmebildkameras eingesetzt
vitalia an keinem der in frage
[Musik]
in
kaarst battaglia verschuldeten wir auch
ihre familie
[Musik]
nicht in großbritannien finden würden
unter die lupe nimmt die gleiche
aufzuspüren
[Musik]
januar 2007 schon sich der ersehnte
durch julian zu können auf dem landsitz
in bernhausen die leiche einer jungen
frau gefunden
ein mangel die sie beim gassi gehen
[Musik]
sie wurde unter erde verscharrt
die leiche war stark verwest die lage
zwischen 14 monaten
die frau war weiß und dass sie sich
große halle angepassten zu etablieren
endlich auf und bezogen
dennoch ist die hoffnung
der
untersuchung wurde der opfer 15 124
doch wie sich heraus
dass nur wenige portugal ist jetzt für
mich auszahlen
[Musik]
aber bisher nicht verstecken
offensichtlich befand sich
damit kam seine gesamte rückreise wurde
in frage
wer interpol übermitteln sie die
satelliten
das angehalten hat an polizeistellen in
allen fünf ländern
geprüft
wie es nichts
die konnten zügig die orte ausschließen
sorgen über
wochen lassen sie alle stellen suchen an
denen die mantas auf seiner rückreise
halt gemacht hat doch jedes mal
das gleiche
danach muss es irgendwie schwierig
werden würde
sie wurde noch immer nicht gefunden
darauf heute sich keine
nicht abgeschlossen wir waren nicht
imstande gewesen ein leicht zu finden
die schwierige zeit
ich hatte unermüdlich an diesem fall
gearbeitet sechs monate
ich hatte viele schlaflose nächte
ich fragte was wir übersehen
hatten wir unsere gelegenheit
beschloss einen tag freizunehmen
heute aber noch sein ich hatte sechs
monate ihres lebens verpasst weil ich
dieser fall sein
ich hatte eine e mail von interpol
bekommen
sie wurde nicht infiziert eine
unbekannte tote mit blonden haaren
[Musik]
als ich diese e-mail
aber die örtliche polizei hatte nicht
mit denen viel abgeglichen aus wir über
interpol ausgesandt hat
ortsansässige handelte die vermisst
wurde
[Musik]
den stellen an denen sie war das
angehalten hatte
[Musik]
laut navi hatte matas den wagen von der
fünf schnelle entfernt
[Musik]
nach sechs monaten intensiver suche
die wir mit einer der härtesten italien
bestritten
hatte wurde herr thoma 2011 geborgen
dieser freund war das entscheidende
stellen diese pose nun sollten wir wie
berichtet
[Musik]
dass zwei vor vitalia schon einmal
auf den 8
[Musik]
dann ist er die 270 euro
er hat sein konto in den frühen
morgenstunden dieser stoff und italiens
wo er gelebt
abgewartet
[Gelächter]
ein extremes risiko im würgegriff toren
führte bis zum ende der straße
[Musik]
aber wir wissen auch von leuten welche
angst sie vorhin hat
als er sie gepackt hat doch konnte er so
ziemlich machen was er
aber er hat ihre schreiben unterdrückt
[Musik]
50 minuten später
wahrscheinlich hat er zuerst mit ihr
gebrochen
bauten diese 8
gelegen
deshalb sei das risiko
hätte er sich den sicherheitskontrollen
was ging ihm wohl wichtiger er braucht
ein ticket kaufte er umziehen öffnen von
40 am 12 august 2011
[Musik]
ein und kaufte das ticket
hatte
italien
[Musik]
auch die passkontrollen
sein herz muss bis zum hals
im moment seien
aufs festland schaffen
sagen kritiker den kanal über gedauert
hat war durch frankreich belgien holland
deutschland und polen gefahren
erreichte er das gebiet gelebt haben
soll
[Musik]
es ist sie eine ärztliche gegend
kilometer
[Musik]
in den aktiven mitarbeit in den wald
tragen dort hob er in die kinos
[Musik]
vitalia league holen zurück
die restlichen 800 kilometer nach hause
befördern
ganz schlechten tag damit verbracht
ermöglichen
aber vergessen sie zu beseitigen
einstimmig für schuldig
hmm
der prozess endete sehr emotional
das ist ein großes privileg es der
siedlung zu leiten und einer familie
getötet
[Musik]
als er den begehrten das navi zu
entsorgen dann hätte er den perfekten
mord
[Musik]
ist das traurig ist dass ein kind seiner
mutter verloren der vater ins
tragische ende einer frau aus die
ohnehin schon so viel durchgemacht hatte
[Musik]